fabrice di vizio avocat du collectif c
19 ont soit fabrice di vizio merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france vous êtes justement à l'origine
de plusieurs plaintes contre des
responsables des ministres dans cette
affaire de gestion du kobe 19
quand vous entendez jérôme salomon dire
la réponse de terrain a été de haut
niveau par beaucoup de pays peuvent se
targuer en gros d'avoir géré aussi bien
quelle est votre réaction
ma réaction c'est d'abord d'être sûr
maintenant qu'on n'aura rien à attendre
de cette commission denquête je le
savais mais maintenant j'en suis certain
les réponses qui ont été faites par
jérôme salomon je les écoutais un jérôme
salomon tout au long de sa pénible
interventions et bien jérôme salomon
parle de jérôme salomon jérôme salomon
félicite jérôme salomon mais jérôme
salomon à ne par là jamais des victimes
jérôme salomon chauffer comme si elle
pas eu trente mille morts et jérôme
seulement oublie que juste à côté de
chez nous par exemple l'allemagne ça lui
a été rappelé plusieurs fois d'ailleurs
pour la commission a beaucoup mieux géré
que nous donc il faut arrêter
jérôme salomon a envie de se féliciter
jérôme salomon m jérôme salomon mais
c'est tout ce que cette réponse à
apporter finalement vous dit jérôme
salle à manger rom c'est non non ils
défendent est aussi peut-être le
gouvernement est ce que c'est la faute
de jérôme salomon s'il n'y avait pas
assez de masse qu'il n'y avait pas assez
de test alors ça c'est ce que l' enquête
devra montrer précisément mais en tout
cas ce que je sais c'est que jérôme
salomon est pour l'instant visé par une
enquête préliminaire du parquet et que
les réponses qu'il devra faire aux
officiers de police et qui plus est au
juge d'instruction
dès qu'une information judiciaire sera
ouverte seront d'un autre acabit seront
d'une autre envergure que celle qui l'a
fait devant la commission denquête
devant laquelle soyons clairs il est
chez lui
aujourd'hui on a assisté à un entre soi
on a assisté à la république qui
finalement d'un côté s'auto congratulent
et de l'autre fait semblant de
posez des questions qui fâchent alors
que fondamentalement celui à qui elles
sont posées a le loisir et le luxe de ne
pas y répondre
et bien moi je vous garantis pour
assister des clients régulièrement dans
le jeu d'instructions que c'est pas tout
à fait comme ça que ça se passe dans le
cabinet d'un juge
alors le procureur françois molins a
annoncé aujourd'hui 84 plein temps au
total contre le gouvernement auprès de
la cour de justice de la république dont
la vôtre d'ailleurs c'est vrai que ça
fait beaucoup 84 plainte
ça fait beaucoup mais il ya eu trente
mille morts d'ailleurs c'est à dire qu'à
un moment donné et vous avez surtout un
gouvernement qui a menti de bout en bout
et si vous voulez ce genre d'attitude de
jérôme salomon arrogante suffisante ne
va pas arranger les choses
aujourd'hui les français vous avez vu
concrètement ce qui se passe notre
reportage l'a montré nous avons d'un
côté les manifestations de soignants qui
demande des réponses concrètes tangibles
et vous avez de l'autre une assemblée
nationale qui d'un côté s'auto
congratulent et de l'autre fait de la
politique politicienne
c'est plus possible sa plus aujourd'hui
ce que les français veulent ce que les
soignants veulent c'est des réponses
concrètes à des problèmes concrets ça
suffit le temps de l'autocongratulation
l'otan de l'autocongratulation pardon et
finalement le taux de l'autosuffisance
doit être terminé et c'est bien ça que
rappelle ces plaintes c'est un ras le
bol des français un ras-le-bol qu'on
leur mente un ras-le-bol qu'on dit c'est
de la faute d'un système mais finalement
c'est de la faute de personne comme si
le système se dirige à tout seul il ya
qu'en france on voit ça ça suffit
maintenant
mais fabrice di vizio je me fais
évidemment l'avocat du diable ici mais
il n'y a pas un peu de vrai ce que c'est
pas cette lourdeur administrative de la
france qui vient d'être révélée dans
cette gestion de la crise du duc o vie
de 19 ans on sait tous que les masques
voilà aurait pu être commandées avant
ils n'ont pas été avant même le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
justement peut-être que ces personnes
trouvent tout simplement injuste d'être
visés pénalement et à titre finalement
personnel
enfin oui sans doute il ya une part de
responsabilités systémiques sans doute
mais maintenant concrètement c'est quand
même pas moins qu'ils aient reçu des
alertes au début janvier
c'est quand même pas le gouvernement de
marisol touraine ou de françois hollande
qui a reçu effectivement des alertes
tout début janvier de la part de pékin
selon lesquelles un vie
l'immortel circulaient et qu' il allait
être mondiale enfin je veux dire c'est
exactement ce que dit agnès buzyn pardon
mais d'ailleurs jérôme salomon la plus
ou moins aujourd'hui confirmée on a des
alertes qui ont été donné très tôt
qu'est ce qu'on a fait est-ce qu'on a
réagi absolument pas regardez monsieur
véran par exemple au jour hier où je
sais plus quand semaine dernière dans
l'agora a dit que les généralistes n'ont
pas pu masquer parce qu'ils n'en avaient
pas besoin
dans la mesure où ils n'ont pas vu de
patients enfin on sait tous que c'est
faux donc on sait tous que ces
gouvernements monde ment honteusement
regarder sans fabrice di vizio que l'eau
à metz avait dit la même chose
effectivement sur les masques on en
n'avait pas forcément besoin au début
non non non le ms à poser un débat sur
les masques grand public que je veux
bien admettre et c'est tout je vient
d'admettre avec une pointe de réserve
mais je veux mettre mes sur les
soignants le problème ne s'est jamais
posée absolument jamais mais sur le 10
mai sur le public c'est un autre débat
sur le public ya aucun débat sur le fait
que en plus en cas de pandémie grippale
par exemple nous avons des plans qui
suggère de manière constante des masques
pour le grand public aujourd'hui on
feint d'ignorer que finalement il
fallait des masques mais c'est une chose
de rodez et de prévu et l'om est ce
effectivement n'a jamais contredit la
nécessité de masques il a tempéré en
disant que bon il appartenait aux états
de choisir en fonction des éléments
culturels
mais ensuite effectivement c'est à
l'état de décider fabrice di vizio à
propos des masques et les commandes
faites par l'état ne sont pas vraiment
transparente
on est donc le secret d'état dans ce cas
là on peut vraiment évoqué un secret
d'état sont ses commandes de masques
alors que les régions sont plutôt
transparente non c'est parfaitement
clair non j'ai le premier fait sommation
à olivier ferrand de nous donner la
copie des bons de commande et face à son
refus j'ai saisi la cour de shiso
république pour une raison simple c'est
qu'en fait aucun vaste que n'a été
commandé
maintenant c'est une certitude et 2 fait
les bons de commande sont des documents
administratifs communicables c'est la
jurisprudence de la cad à venir à venir
évoquer le secret des affaires et d'une
supercherie intellectuelle
justifie les plaintes pénales et je ne
comprends pas que la commission denquête
n'est pas commencer par ça en exigeant
les boums commandes
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
la première réalité c'est quand même
d'exiger sur pièce la réalité de ce qui
a été fait et qu'on arrête des discours
inutiles
que pourrait-on découvrir avec ses bons
de commande s'ils étaient publiées dont
on pourrait surtout découvrir qui
n'existe pas c'est surtout ça qu'on
pourrait découvrir c'est qu'en réalité
il n'ya pas eu de bons de commande je
pense qu'on va découvrir qu'en réalité
les bons commandes ont été extrêmement
tardif et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on n'a pas réussi à se procurer
de masques je suis quasiment sûre
aujourd'hui au regard de la réticence de
l'état est au faîte du fait qu'il est
mal à l'aise à ce point que au fond il
ya une fine il ya une défaillance sur ce
point je le dis depuis le premier jour
il ya une défaillance au niveau de
l'état s'agissant des masques et moi je
suis quasiment certain que ce thème à ce
que nous ont été commandés que
extrêmement tardivement et que c'est la
raison pour laquelle on donne autant de
mal on a autant de mal à les communiquer
qu'est ce que ça coûte de les
communiquer ça ne peut que rapporter
gros de communiquer les bons de commande
ça montre à quel point avec billie jean
à quel point c'est pas de notre faute si
on refuse quelque chose qu'à un tel
bénéfice politique c'est que
nécessairement il ya un loup quelque
part ça breezy le géoparc wa par
négligence par incompétence
on n'aurait pas commander ces masques en
temps et en heure au canada sans doute
par inconscience probablement parce que
quand j'entends olivier derand dire que
les généralistes mais a besoin de
masques
je me demande si on vit dans le même
monde quand même et je me demande si
tout ça a pas une pointe de cynisme
lorsqu on sait qu effectivement des
médecins sont morts je me demande quand
même à quoi joue le gouvernement
et c'est bien pour ça je vais vous dire
que j'ai demandé moi officiellement
aujourd'hui à ce que les victimes soient
entendus que je représente soit entendu
par la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
c'est pas une option c'est pas un débat
soit elles sont entendues soit la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire et
des saisies par une à part l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire que je
provoquerais dès la semaine prochaine
merci fabrice indivision avocat du
collectif c 19 d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france